jennifer rubin who used to pretend to be
a conservative columnist at the
washington post now i think she's
basically open about being a liberal
columnist she tweets out this article
and she says quote a more diverse more
inclusive society this is fabulous news
now we need to prevent minority white
rule
of course it is
cliche i shouldn't even say it i'm so i
don't even want to say it but of course
if any columnist said this about any
other racial group they would be called
a vile vicious racist and rightly so but
jennifer rubin because she's saying it
about white people is not called that in
that imagi i can't i hate this because
truly conservatism is going to die
because we keep playing these
hypotheticals and say well you know if
the shoe was on the other foot but you
know if she tweeted out
because the let's say the black
population was decreasing a more diverse
more inclusive society this is fabulous
news now we need to prevent minority
black rule obviously she'd be run out of
town she'd have her entire career
destroyed but because it's against white
people it's perfectly fine jennifer
rubin is not the only person saying this
you hear it actually from elected
democrats ilhan omar just some months
ago came out and said this
is not not going to this country is not
for white people and white people better
pack up and head on out this is not
going to be the country of white people
so and there are so many more examples
of this
so from what i can conclude if you say
that
white people are diminishing as a
portion of the population and you
suggest that either that's neutral or a
bad thing you're a vile vicious
conspiracy theorist racist if you make
the exact same odd observation but you
celebrate it you are a good wonderful
person who supports diversity and a
thriving america
i'm glad you love that clip
i love that clip too
you know what you'll love even more
the michael knowles show podcast which
you can get at apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcast go there right now
oh good and subscribe and leave a
five-star review very much appreciate it
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you